ich muss heute abend schon wieder über
karl lauterbach sprechen ich weiß die
stammzuschauer ihnen gerne schon nicht
mehr hören können und denken oh nein
schon wieder aber es wird immer
schlimmer also wenn man meint da kommt
kein neuer lauterbach klubs da kommt
doch wieder einer um die ecke was ist
denn eigentlich passiert lauterbach
warnt aktuell vor einer kroner sommer
welle mein haar ist und mit varianten zu
tun die sich auch im sommer gut
ausbreiten könnten zitat die
angekündigte sommer welle ist leider
realität geworden das bedeutet auch für
die nächsten wochen wenig entspannen
sagte lauterbach der rheinischen post
bereits am dienstag hatte lauterbach
dazu aufgerufen wegen der sprunghaft
steigenden kroner zeit in innenräumen
wieder schutzmasken zu tragen dies und
eine vierte impfung seien die wirksamste
gegenmittel
ich möchte es hier einmal klar
formuliert mein problem liegt darin karl
lauterbach lag so oft falsch es ist mich
persönlich nicht interessiert was er
glaubt sagt will oder meint und das
deutsche cohen erzeugen ist was
wesentlich wichtiger ist meine
einschätzung wie kalau dabei ist ist
mangelhaft deutschland hat in der korona
krise nicht besser performance andere
länder wie beispielsweise schweben und
deswegen möchte ich hier ganz klar dazu
aufrufen dass wir nicht schon wieder in
panik machen verfallen und möchte er
bosbach fragen was befähigt herr
lauterbach denn eigentlich jetzt dazu
mir wahrscheinlich wieder zu diktieren
wie ich mit krone umgehen soll er hat
zwei jahre lang gut geformt um das mal
aufzugreifen in sämtlichen talkshows der
republik teilweise mehrfach am abend mit
3 formulierungen erster er habe in
harvard studiert zweitens er würde alle
neue studien kennen und drittens die
stammen von exzellenten fachleute die er
natürlich alle persönlich kennt das hat
leute tief beeindruckt ich war mir am
ende nicht mehr ganz sicher wer jetzt
bei wem zu gast ist ist jetzt langt's
bei lauterbach zu gast oder doch
umgekehrt und dann fiel den ersten auf
übrigens im zdf morgenmagazin
viele stimmt ja gar nicht was du warst
der erzählt und dann gab es die regens
ausfallen meldet musste sich sofort
vorwurf gefallen lassen eine kampagne zu
schlachten mit immer dann gemacht wenn
man in der sache den vorwurf nicht
widerlegen kann dann wurde es verdächtig
ruhig ich darf man es passiert dann kam
die keller variante dann kam die killer
variante da haben selbst fachleute
gesagt kann es reicht ist es gut die hat
er ja für den herbst in aussicht
gestellt es ist nicht die aufgabe eines
bundesgesundheitsministers panik zu
verbreiten
es ist die aufgabe seriös die lage zu
schildern und mit fachleuten
empfehlungen abzugeben aber viele hatten
jedenfalls zunächst so eine art
urvertrauen sehr ist gesundheitsökonom
ein studierter mediziner der muss mehr
ahnung haben als andere epidemiologe da
hat man gesagt der wird der wird es wohl
wissen dann ist er auf dieser welle
geschwommen wurde gar eingetragen in das
gesundheitsministerium dann hat man
gesehen moment ist doch was anderes ob
man talkshow gast ist oder im
ministerium aber wenn man so oft falsch
lag die herr lauterbach das haben wir ja
auch bei bild das muss man gestehen er
hat sich auch immer dazu scheiden lassen
ist auch eine gang auf kritik das machen
weniger so wie er aber wenn man so oft
falsch lag wie kann man denn dann
eigentlich auch noch diese
selbstgerechtigkeit haben jetzt immer
weiter zu prognostizieren was jetzt
passiert dass wir jetzt die cholera
sommer welle haben ich muss sagen ich
bin ein bisschen enttäuscht von karl
lauterbach nach der killer variante
hatte ich mir jetzt eigentlich eine
steigerung erhofft stattdessen kommt die
sommer wendet das klingt so ein bisschen
wie check24 de angebote jetzt aber nix
wie raus
das ist mir ein bisschen zu soft ich
also bewährt gruseln liebt der ist jetzt
enttäuscht aber im ernst wir haben es in
der ganzen corona zeit eigentlich mit
unterschiedlichen segmenten zu tun
gehabt karl lauterbach gehört zu denen
ich unterstelle dass er das glaubt was
er sagt ist ja nicht zwingend bei
politikern sorry ich wollte das reiche
aus dem boden geholt
karl lauterbach gehört zu der mentalität
die sagen es wird alles schlimm wir
müssen vorsicht auch wenn man noch nicht
genau weiß was der herbst bringt
vorsicht wir müssen erstmal vorsorgen
das trifft auf eine breite stimmung aber
auch draußen im land also wenn wir jetzt
auf die straße gehen treffen wir
andauernd leute die draußen mit ihrem
hund mit einer maske rumlaufen und man
sofort warum ist er oder merck ist der
hund und die anderen die sagen hey es
ist vorbei mein nachbar hat aber der ist
fröhlich und
im urlaub es ist alles diese
unterschiedlichen grund veranlagungen
die kriegt man nicht raus und karl
lauterbach ist unseliger weise mit einem
amt belastet wo er permanent seinen
seinem sensors da auslebt und ständig
vor etwas warnt auch vor dingen vor der
uns gar nicht retten kann also wenn man
nicht weiß welche variante im herbst
nominiert kann ich auch keinen impfstoff
hin geschweige denn dass ich eine
pflicht für etwas beschließen von dem
ich nicht weiß wozu ich die leute
verpflichten will das ist hochgradig
absurd und das ist eigentlich bosbachs
gesagt also der gesundheitsminister der
mehr verunsicherung verbreitet als dass
er ein gefühl von sicherheit
ausgibt der ist glaube ich auf dem
falschen posten
wir wollen uns heute enthüllen
haben sie denn jetzt schon angst vor der
korona sommer welle und sind sie auch
dafür wieder masken im innenraum zu
tragen da selbstverständlich nicht ich
glaube was man bei herrn lauterbach vor
allen dingen feststellen muss aber erst
bei weitem nicht der einzige politiker
deshalb mit dem wort vorsorge auf eine
art und weise umgeht die mich als
wissenschaftler und auch als mutter
regelrecht fassungslos macht denn
vorsorge ist hier nicht das hat er
vorschlägt sondern vorsorge wäre jetzt
alle bürger dazu aufrufen die masken
endlich abzulegen und die sommerzeit
englich den dritten corona sommer dazu
zu nutzen dass wir eine immunisierung
werden immunisierung bekommen das war
nie günstiger als heute das sagen wir
seit omikron und anstatt das zu tun was
andere allerdings getan haben wir
müssten auch keine vorreiter sein wir
könnten ganz konservativ schweden und
dänemark und anderen europäischen
ländern folgen die das längst vollzogen
haben und dafür sorgen dass wir mit
einem gestärkten immunsystem in den
winter gehen das wäre die aufgabe eines
ministers der selbst für sich in
anspruch im wissenschaftlich zu agieren
und dann muss ich die worte nicht
wiederholen das gegenteil ist der fall
und ich persönlich habe keine angst vor
corinna ich hab's gehabt meine familie
gehabt und wir werden es alle irgendwann
bekommen und im übrigen verhält es sich
inzwischen wie eine grippe keine
angenehme aber gibt aber auch vorher
nicht herzstücke der herr laut aber
spricht ja nicht nur über corona sondern
auch über die affen brocken ist es denn
was wovor sie jetzt angst haben also ich
bin ja zum glück kein politiker und
möchte ich auch gar keiner sein ich kann
ja nichts sondern beherrscht er
eigentlich nur die kunst ist dabei sein
und dabei ein bisschen lustig und
bisschen schön und ich hinterfrage mich
zb auch selten ob lauterbach jetzt recht
hat oder nicht oder ob das jetzt
panikmache ist oder nicht aber ich
erwarte von politikern dass sie mir auch
etwas vorgeben und ich möchte zum
beispiel als künstler nicht immer
pausenlos jetzt auch noch damit
beschäftigt sein müssen zu hinterfragen
ob das was er laut aber sagt stimmt bei
erst habe ich keine lust und keine zeit
dafür sondern ich muss auftreten und wir
künstler also ich bin ja heute
stellvertretend für für alle künstler
heute auch so ein bisschen hier wir sind
ja froh dass er wieder auftreten können
und dass jetzt die leute wieder ins
theater können und dass wir wieder film
mitreden können und so weiter weil wir
haben ja auch sehr schwere jahre jetzt
hinter uns auch die
veranstaltungsbranche alles was mit
bühnen haben sie auch noch geld verloren
an der colonia ja natürlich also wir
konnten ja nirgendwo mehr auftreten ich
moderiere ja auch viel also was soll ich
moderieren ich konnte zu hause
moderieren wenn ich morgens aufgestanden
bin und dann ins bad gern bin hätte ich
mir künstlichen applaus erstellen können
unheimlich gefreut dass heute quasi noch
ein neuer tag es deswegen also ich
erwarte eigentlich mehr oder weniger von
lauterbach dass er quasi die prognosen
macht die dann auch ein treffen aber ich
möchte jetzt quasi nicht jeden tag jetzt
in eine künstliche panikmache gebracht
werden also ich möchte auch nicht jeden
tag jetzt überlegen was jetzt nächsten
monat los ist sondern ich möchte
politiker haben und da wenn ich zum
beispiel bei dir immer wenn du sprichst
dann glaube ich dass auch und ich glaube
auch dass du es weiß und bei anderen
wünsche ich mit ist und bei lauterbach
denke ich manchmal ja was ist denn jetzt
schon wieder was hast du denn schon
wieder manchmal denke ich vielleicht
muss ich doch in die politik gehen
stellen sie sich mal vor ich wäre der
politik wie glamourös aussehen würde
wenn ich im plenum sagt zuwendet
aber ich meine da sind wir ja eigentlich
sehr ernsten punkt das amt was
lauterbach begleitet ist sehr ernst es
verwaltet unsere volksgesundheit es ist
dafür zuständig dass millionen menschen
im gesundheitswesen die hart arbeiten
vernünftig bezahlt werden dass die
vernünftige heilbehandlungen anbieten
dass wir wirklich das anbieten was wir
auf unserem wohlstandsniveau den
menschen geben können und da ist es
eigentlich ziemlich unangemessen wenn
der minister seinen posten auf eine art
und weise ausfüllt dass man ich wollte
von vorschlagen wir machen eine
talkrunde die lauterbachs und sind dass
diese und saftigkeit die kann man sich
einen augenblick erlauben aber auf dem
posten kann man sie sich nicht erlauben
und das haben auch die leute im
gesundheitswesen nicht verdient wir
haben jetzt bei den krankenkassen ein
loch von geschäfts 20 milliarden 25
milliarden euro das muss geschickt das
ist die aufgabe des auch des
gesundheitsministers dass zu moderieren
und zu sagen wo kommt das geld her damit
die leute dort anständig bezahlt wären
das ist ein haufen arbeit und eigentlich
kann man sich nicht erlauben dann mit
solchen seltsamen prognosen ins blaue
hinein die überhaupt nicht gekoppelt
sind mit dem alltag der leute sein
renommee zu verspielen das ist wirklich
eigentlich ein großes problem auch für
olaf scholz und sein kabinett